this man is in fuego he got lanier
dominguez
absolutely on fire winning four in a row
lanier you started off this tournament
not so great how did you catch fire like
you did to win four in a row yeah i
don't know i usually i don't do very
well at the very start it usually takes
me some games to
at least
play decent but yeah it was working
really well especially today i think in
the first two games especially i was
playing really well like from the start
uh even in one of the games i was using
some some prep that we did and uh
and okay in the last game i was i was
under pressure i didn't play very well
in the opening i think and i i felt that
i was under pressure most of the time
but i i was hanging in there and then
i think i
i played well practically i was keeping
some chances
and and i was lucky that he he just
blundered his queen a6 move at the end
this game i really like this move king
to h8 you don't get to play moves like
this every day yeah i was already i mean
i saw this rook jason come in and but i
it's just i mean it's so winning because
i have so much material and and his king
is also
weak and yeah i was calculating and i i
saw the whole line in advance that
that's why i played quickly
well this was the game was against uh
shakur mamadirov
it's been a top sea turvy tournament it
looks like for everybody nobody has been
played perfect chess everybody has lost
at least one game
what's it going to take to win this
tomorrow yeah i think
it's it comes down to
this middle game if you are able to
solve problems quickly and to
just to avoid blunders then
you will do well so i'll i'll try my
best
well thanks so much good luck tomorrow
thank you